[Musique]
solidarité la vérité solidarité
démocratie encrassent les me pratte est
ressassé parité bonjour bonsoir puisque
je ne sais pas quelle heure me regarder
toute façon chez nous très tard ou
traitant on a droit à un bon quart
d'heure pour cette nouvelle émission de
la campagne officielle on a choisi
autour de dominique voynet de rassembler
un certain nombre de gens qui vont
parler de thèmes divers et qui surtout
représente un petit peu la variété des
soutiens à la candidature de dominique
alors je voulais présente rapidement
gilbert vasseur wasserman qui est là
comme porte parole de la convention
alternative progressiste marie christine
blandin que vous connaissez sûrement qui
est la présidente depuis 92 maintenant
de la région nord pas de calais dont peu
grosse responsabilité
roger winterhalter qui est le porte
parle de l'alternative rouge et verte
merde
lutterbach monsieur pietrasanta yves
pietrasanta qui lui est maire aussi
d'une vie s'appelle mèze et qui est
conseiller régional dans le languedoc ça
vous montre un peu la diversité de ses
soutiens et aussi les responsabilités
qu'on les gens autour de dominique qui
ne sont pas simplement des militants de
terrain mais qui sont aussi engagés des
postes institutionnels nous avons aussi
dominique fra ger qui lui est
maire-adjoint plus spécialement chargé
de la santé a colombes est aussi
conseiller régional d'ile-de-france et
marie anne isler béguin
vous connaissez aussi qui est l'ancienne
vice présidente du parlement européen et
porte parole des verts
voilà alors chacun de vous va nous dire
en quelques mots un petit peu de parler
un petit peu son action sur le terrain
nous dire aussi pourquoi il l'a choisi
de soutenir dominique voynet et on va
commencer par la plus gradée les tiens
marie christine blandin comment ça se
passe dans le nord pas de calais qu'elle
qu'est ce que ça apporte à une région
grandes régions comme le nord pas de
calais une présidence différente de
celle des partis traditionnels les
différences et le scrutin proportionnel
qui a permis l'arrivée d'une écologiste
disons le minoritaire et qui fait que
chez nous il n'ya pas une majorité de
51% qui opprime et qui coupe les parents
les moyens de la minorité de 49%
comme ça se passe dans beaucoup
d'assemblées chez nous le débat est roi
et il ya plus d'intelligence dans la
tête de 113 élus qui discutent qui
confrontent leurs idées que dans la tête
d'une majorité qui confie ce que le
pouvoir n'ont pas le droit c'est pas
trop le
le bordel comme but effectivement on est
obligé de composer on est obligé de
partager on est obligé de d'amender les
projets et comment avec un débat aussi
large peut-on conserver l'écologie parce
que le danger serait de prendre le plus
petit commun dénominateur et ben en
instaurant la démocratie participative
en informant les quatre millions
d'habitants de nos projets du réel de
nos impossibilité de nos possibilités en
les associant au choix en amont en
corrigeant selon ce qui nous renvoie je
prenais seul exemple la coopération
décentralisée région la plus pauvre de
france le plus grand nombre de chômeurs
région la plus jeune est ce bien
raisonnable d'aller mettre de l'argent
régionales vers le tiers monde et va
quand les gens savent que le but que
nous poursuivons un pour cent de
l'argent ça représente 40 fois plus
proportionnellement que les autres
régions mais un kilomètre d'autoroute
il serait prêt à mettre 10 fois plus et
associer les gens la décision c'est la
garantie de la démocratie c'est la
garantie la compréhension
la démarche de dominique qui convoie
donc cette campagne des présidentielles
qui essaye de faire passer notre message
je pense qu'elle est fondamentale elles
montrent qu a pas de solutions toutes
faites les gens cherchent le net et la
volonté et ils veulent discuter des
solutions techniques vous n'avez pas de
trop de problèmes mandé vote
votre assemblée vous arrivez à vous en
sortir a voté le budget il ya des
régions on n'arrive pas à des régions
dont les grands prêtres sont les tenants
de la majorité absolue bas ils
n'arrivent pas à voter leur budget en
arrive aux délais de rigueur ils n'ont
pas de budget ils n'ont pas réussi à
dégager une majorité
alors qu'avec notre proportionnelle
notre système d'animation notre recours
à la population eh ben ça marche
les autres conseillers régionaux l'avons
confirmé cette vision des choses
la sabam et l'arrivée des écologistes
avec un ciré jeunes ont apporté un
séminaire à la politique dépoussiérer la
façon de faire la politique
traditionnelle
et il faut voir le bilan des conseils
régionaux qui sont vraiment attachés à
leur région et qui est très important à
une adhésion
c'est quelque chose de très innovant je
crois alors un maire maintenant un maire
alternatif qu'est-ce que tu es ce que
son spécial qu'est ce que ça fait
spéciale sur le terrain commence à agir
savine enfin s'il ya quelque chose de
spécial bon je suis pas fou j'étais né
pendant la panne à la deuxième guerre
mondiale je crois que ça m'a beaucoup
marqué parce que notre village a été
sinistrée presque 100%
et puis ensuite j'ai l'habitude de dire
que je suis un militant né de la guerre
d'algérie on a pris ce qu'on appelle le
pouvoir municipal en 77 et puis depuis
ça dure
77 77 j'étais à l'époque j'appartenais
encore au psu dont je reste attaché à
ses à ses idées assez à cet idéal
et puis on s'est dit ah ben avec nos
moyens avec nos possibilités de limites
on va essayer de mettre en pratique un
certain nombre de choses
expérimenté sur le terrain parce que je
crois que les municipalités sont un très
bon terrain d'expérimentation on est
aussi la première ville à s'être
déclarés zones dénucléarisées à la fois
pour un symbole mais aussi par
solidarité avec ces genres de tchernobyl
et depuis les enfants viennent d
des scientifiques viennent également
discuter avec nous sur les énergies
renouvelables
là on a eu un échec on a voulu avoir un
projet de géothermie
et puis qui ne s'est pas réalisé parce
qu'en france je crois gauche-droite un
seul combat pour le tue nous tout
nucléaire il faut bien le dire
et puis mon nous on pense à autre chose
je crois qu'il faut aussi faire le bilan
de ces échecs mais parallèlement on a on
l'a aussi lié à ce que j'appelle à hier
jeudi ça il faut se donner la main
aujourd'hui on dit les solidarités
solidarité avec les plus démunis
en fait toute une série de projets pour
l'insertion sociale par l'économique
on a lancé là on a une association
intermédiaire qui est né n'est rien
d'autre qu'un bureau de placement à but
non lucratif ont fait des chantiers
professionnels pour des contrats emploi
solidarité on a des entreprises
d'insertion notamment la brasserie parce
que ça vire basri comme l'alsacienne
pipeline de l'oeil et puis là on a elle
est fermée depuis 69 et on a relancé une
brasserie artisanale ou qui embauchent à
la fois des gens qualifiés et des gens
nous qualifier mais je crois que là
aussi on a compris aux limites et ça ne
suffit pas je crois que actuellement
dans la situation de chômage crois qu'il
faut aller au delà je pense qu'on
parlera de la réduction de temps de
travail
bon public fera gère les problèmes de
santé vous c'est votre domaine
c'est aussi une des spécialités de ce
qu'il t'a fait rappelons le quand même
mettre sa comment vous comment vous
gérez ça dans une grande ville dans une
grande ville donc comme que l'ombre qui
est une grande ville de l'agglomération
parisienne
évidemment le premier problème c'est je
dirais avec la crise et le chômage dont
les sites est à moi j'avais une cité
populaire de 2000 personnes et je vois
depuis depuis 20 ans je vois bien la
dégradation et les problèmes y compris
de de santé au sens large du terme que
nous que nous rencontrons aussi bien
pour les personnes âgées que pour les
plus jeunes c'est d'abord l'accès aux
soins
tout bêtement c'est une question qu'on
pensait régler les problèmes comme ça
qu'on croyait régler les acquis et qui
ne le sont pas l'accès aux soins pour
tous y compris c'est la solidarité comme
disait roger pour les plus démunis qui
parfois
bon sont toxicomanes par exemple avec un
sida qui galope dans mon département qui
était le plus riche de france dit-on ins
et hauts-de-seine
il y entre décembre 92 et décembre 93
caisse en cas de sida 31 %
d'augmentation comme taux de progression
et une singularité terrible un mode de
contamination les changes seringues
souillées chez les toxicomanes alors
voilà pourquoi par exemple quand il ya
urgence
je dirais priorité pour limiter la casse
il faut avoir des actions très concrètes
sur le terrain je perds wassermann le
social dans cette campagne il est un
petit peu le représentant de 2,7 de
cette mouvance qui qu'il a rejointe
petit à petit ou du moins une
convergence entre entre vos sensibilités
et où vous retrouvez donc aujourd'hui à
soutenir dominique comment vous avez
vécu cette campagne quels sont les
thèmes que vous voulez porter en
priorité je ne serai pas seule fois le
représentant du social lors du naufrage
je suis aussi l'écologie je veux dire
par là que pour ce qui nous concerne
nous qui définissons comme la gauche
alternative
c'est vrai qu'une pour beaucoup d'entre
nous nous venons de la gauche
traditionnelle même justement nous avons
tiré le bilan de ces échecs de ces
impasses et nous essayons de construire
un nouveau projet et pour construire un
nouveau projet mais il nous semble
indispensable de rencontrer l'écologie
et c'est pour ça que nous plaidons pour
un véritable mariage du socialisme et de
l'écologie au fond les logiques du
productivisme exacerbée et des logiques
de l'argent roi de la recherche du
profit maximum
c'est quand même fort les mêmes logiques
c'est une idée qui vend ça c'était le
titre d'un grand quotidien du soir hier
si mais je te vends une nous nous sommes
très contents que deux mini grenelle et
pu tout au long de cette campagne
commencé à avancer ses idées là et je
crois que c'est les idées de l'avenir
c'est les idées du rassemblement
nous avons à faire mais alors est-ce que
le mammifère beggas que justement a
contrario on peut pas dire que cette
campagne a un peu passer sous la table
des vrais problèmes l'écologie qu'est ce
qu'on pense la pompe a relevé
maintenant on reproche qu'on entende
pendant temps pas du tout parce que la
preuve est faite que aujourd'hui nombre
de partenaires ont intégré aujourd'hui
l'écologie
pour nous l'écologie c'est un tout le
social est intégré dans l'écologie
l'environnement est intégré dans
l'écologie donc je crois qu'il ya encore
quelques pas en avant à faire mais c'est
vrai qu'il faut le rappeler quand même
l'environnement c'était le premier
combat des écologistes il ya 20 ans rené
dumont monsieur mono jean pierre raffin
ce sont les personnes qui portent qui
ont porté ces les couleurs de l'écologie
depuis 20 ans aujourd'hui elle se
concrétise par des élus dans les
différentes institutions
moi même j'étais pendant cinq ans au
parlement européen où nous avons
réellement travailler nous avons essayé
de montrer que aussi bien en france en
europe dans les pays de l'est que dans
les pays du sud aujourd'hui nous devons
passer un développement écologiquement
soutenable ce que nous ce que nous
appelons ici la transformation
écologique de la société
donc c'est vrai que en regardant ce qui
est fait en france en acquérant
environnement plus particulièrement si
on n'avance pas riou c'était il ya trois
ans berlin c'était yahia et c'était hier
rien n'avance pour vous donner juste un
chiffre le chiffre du budget du
ministère de l'environnement 1,7
milliard ce qui équivaut au
fonctionnement de la très grande
bibliothèque nationale donc c'est que
aujourd'hui le choix politique qui est
fait en france c'est pas le choix de la
santé c'est pas le choix de
l'environnement c'est pas le choix de
l'écologie c'est pas le choix du social
on ne m'a pas envie d'investir ni dans
l'onu dans l'air alors que votre
prochain
trouver là je ne prendrai ce que dit
marine iii faut vraiment être des
écologistes de terrain c'est sur le
terrain qu'on peut faire le
développement local est relié avec
développement durable dont elle parle et
on peut parler des grands problèmes de
dominique a parlé dans la campagne toile
mais deux des problèmes des déchets de
leur recyclage
la propreté de l'eau la pureté de l'air
c'est très important ce qui se passe
dans nos campagnes de nos villes dans
nos villages c'est très important tout
ça est donc avec le parti écologiste a
montré comment représenter avec
dominique le frère nous nous sommes dit
manistes nous avons pensé que dominique
voynet
c'est vraiment elle qui représente
l'écologie terrain et c'était c'est elle
qui nous présente dans cette campagne
des prêts dylan ou chasse ont écouté
tout ça sans oublier comme le rappelait
marie christine blandin les problèmes de
développement les problèmes nord-sud et
c'est qu'ils sont vraiment je suis au
coeur de notre démarche commune
dominique il t'appartient au plur oui
j'ai eu l'occasion tout au long de cette
campagne de défendre avec beaucoup
d'énergie et de conviction un projet
politique pour entrer dans l'intérim
siècle un projet qui donne tout son sens
à ce terme de développement soutenable
que nous avons mis en avant un projet
qui insiste sur la nécessité de partager
mieux les richesses de diminuer le temps
de travail de pensée des transports
collectifs accessibles et confortable
d'abolir la dette des pays du tiers
monde et de mettre en place des circuits
qui privilégie la coopération
décentralisée les relations directes
entre les gens j'ai eu l'occasion
d'assister sur les dégâts considérables
d'un modèle de développement qui n'était
maîtrisé par personne et qui était en
fête qui s'était emballé sous la
pression des grands lobbys et deux des
grands corps qui sont assez responsables
face aux lois du marché
mais je tenais dans cette phase
terminale de campagne à être entouré ici
les gens qui l'ont fait avec moi cette
campagne et qui font vivre l'écologie
est l'alternative tous les jours sur le
terrain les gens qui sont des élus qui
prennent des responsabilités qui
expérimentent innove qui créent et qui
qui font le lien en permanence entre
l'action au niveau local et la réflexion
pour un nouveau
j'ai deux sociétés qui marie l'écologie
le socialisme la démocratie et qui nous
permettent finalement à nous qui n'avons
pas encore une très longue expérience de
travail en commun de dessiner ce qui
pourrait être un grand mouvement pour
rentrer dans le xxème siècle en portant
l'espoir des gens osent et dominique
voynet
ça change tout
[Rires]
[Musique]
depuis le sommet de rio nous avons connu
les dix années les plus chaudes de
l'humanité rappelez-vous la tempête de
l'hiver 99 la canicule de l'été 2003
l'ouragan katrina dans quinze ans que
répondrez vous à vos enfants quand ils
vous demanderont tu savais tu n'as rien
fait pourquoi on ne fera pas d'écologie
sans les écologistes
je suis la candidate des verts des
écologistes j'ai 48 ans je suis maman de
deux filles
mais ce n'est pas en tant que femme que
je me présente aux élections
présidentielles je suis médecin
j'ai été militant syndical militantes
associatives militantes politiques au
sein des verts je suis élue de
seine-saint-denis
j'ai été ministre je veux à chaque
instant concilier l'action sur le
terrain et le changement des politiques
depuis 20 ans l'écologie c'est vraiment
toute ma vie je suis professeur des
écoles cette année j'ai une classe à
double niveau 1 cp cm2 en classe nous
travaillons sur la révolution française
la révolution industrielle
mais la révolution écologique qu'est ce
que ça veut dire
et surtout comment rendre les enfants
acteurs de cette révolution c'est très
difficile de parler de l'école notre
pays nous avons été des élèves
nous sommes des parents nous connaissons
des enseignants nous avons tous à un
avis sur cette question n'est ce pas
tout simplement incroyable qu'on n'ose
encore demandé à l'école de réparer seul
les dégâts de 30 ans de crise la
situation de la connaissons des réformes
qui s'empilent et qui arrive d'en haut
sans concertation une pression de plus
en plus forte sur les enfants et sur les
enseignants avec des conséquences très
graves
un échec scolaire massif chez des
enfants humiliés cas c'est qu'ils n'ont
plus confiance en eux mêmes une grande
souffrance les enseignants qui aimerait
beaucoup aider leurs élèves qui ont le
sentiment de ne pas pouvoir le faire
et puis une énorme colère à l'égard de
la hiérarchie à l'égard des
gouvernements qui se succèdent et qui
donne l'impression de charger encore et
encore la barque alors les solutions
nous les connaissons et nous avons envie
de
mettre en oeuvre d'abord commencé à
accompagner les familles dès les toutes
premières années un service public de la
petite enfance est indispensable ensuite
revoir et alléger les programmes
scolaires tout n'est pas prioritaire
nous devons faire en sorte que nos
enfants aient des fondations solides
pour leur permettre ensuite de se
préparer à des orientations et des choix
différents au cours de la vie nous
devons cesser de sélectionner par
l'échec retarder le moment de la
sélection et faire en sorte que
l'orientation ne soit pas faite par
défaut mais en fonction des goûts des
priorités et des besoins bien sûr aussi
du marché du travail
nous devons rompre avec un discours qui
laisse croire que non plus à ceux qui
ont moins alors que c'est exactement
l'inversé qui se produit et puis nous
devons permettre aux enseignants de se
recentrer sur leur mission première
enseigne et en faisant entrer d'autres
adultes dans l'école des assistants
d'éducation pour accompagner tous les
temps de la vie scolaire des éducateurs
pour permettre aux enfants handicapés
d'être accueillis effectivement comme le
prévoit la loi mais aussi des
enseignants de langues régionales
des militants associatifs des
représentants des réseaux de l'éducation
populaire c'est cette diversité qui va
permettre à l'école de ne pas être
fermés sur la vie et d'assumer aussi sa
mission culturelle et sa mission
citoyenne en tant que médecin
généraliste je suis de plus en plus
confrontés à des patients qui se posent
des questions sur les nouveaux risques
que ce soit sur la pollution les ogm ou
la grippe aviaire
j'aimerais bien savoir quelles sont les
réponses que la révolution écologique
peut apporter à ces nouveaux risques
je suis moi même médecin je partage
largement vos préoccupations la
quasi-totalité des nouvelles maladies
des nouveaux risques sont liés aux
conditions de vie et de travail aux
conditions d'environnement plus
largement c'est vrai pour la grippe
aviaire largement liée aux conditions
dans les élevages c'est vrai aussi pour
les ogm dont les risques ne sont pas
réellement très bien connu à cette heure
alors nous avons le choix entre deux
stratégies soit réparé les dégâts en
cherchant pour chaque pathologie
nouvelle une molécule miracle soit
mettre en place une stratégie
de précaution de prévention pour réduire
dans l'environnement
les facteurs qui expliquent la
dégradation de la santé pour être très
concret est-ce que nous allons continuer
à chercher une pilule miracle contre
l'obésité ou conseiller un bon équilibre
alimentaire et la pratique d'un exercice
physique régulier
est ce que nous allons dire aux
agriculteurs qui souffrent de stérilité
ou de problèmes immunitaires que ils
doivent tolérer et accepter les
pesticides ou est-ce que nous allons
réduire l' usage de ces molécules
toxiques dans les pratiques agricoles
nous souhaitons donc privilégier la
prévention l'éducation sanitaire
remettre le généraliste au coeur du
système de santé ce qui suppose qu'on
travaille sur les conditions de son
installation dans les quartiers
difficiles dans les zones rurales y
compris financièrement ce qui suppose
aussi qu'on développe des nouvelles
modalités d'exercice des maisons
médicales des réseaux de santé des
centres de santé où les professionnels
et les usagers pourraient travailler
ensemble
l'enjeu est tout simple il s'agit de
passer d'un système de soins qui
fonctionne au profit des professionnels
un système de santé conçu dans l'intérêt
de chacun d'entre nous
[Musique]